I think the building as a as a body
actually one could actually look at it
as a in the urban point of view we
thought that this artwork needed to in
the way add an accent to the street when
we were pushed to do the project we we
felt that the substation should not just
be a venue we wanted to to to make
something or to start something based on
the dialogue between us and the building
so that was how the projects button so
we actually look at the whole site as a
whole and contextualizing it which is
why we started with using it looking at
the facade of the substation as a
starting point itself well I guess
subconsciously we start to personify the
building and we see the building itself
like expected for the end which is why
you know the title of building as a body
and instinctively you know the user or
the selection of them something to tell
or soft you know it became like the
natural choice and all the construction
but I love courses it's dude done in a
very logical and structural manner where
we actually look at the design of the
facade the proportions and you know the
different levels I actually I'm the
design that you derive from the the
actual design of the facade
in terms of the work that we actually
designate that there are certain things
that you can't just ran that truly in
terms of getting the materials and
whatnot and graceful Caltech Delhi and
for my site I'll take care of the
construction drawing and dealing with a
contractor I'm actually quite likely
that that's basically make use of my my
passion training because I realize them
since I'm we were working with all this
some fabric light strip so we actually
got the the supplier to stitch a loop
into the strips so that we could
actually cook them or us like them into
um this metal pole for me I think when I
look at that rope or that fabric it was
more on looking at constructability for
grace I saw in her death that she is
looking at whether it does give a
certain intrinsic quality to it so
there's the soft touch we kind of had a
rough idea where order some key points
would be but we could only tell when we
were on site I'm setting up the
scaffolding
so I mean I'm we always thankful that we
that the length of the fabric strips
that we ordered they were actually I'm
just nice I think there's one take on on
the permanence of this outward instead
if he could bring the rejuvenation of
the other Street we didn't wear this
obsession is with this artwork that I
think we have seceded in in trying to
let this out work speaks for itself when
the project was done when we finish our
with the installation when we looked at
it it felt like it was actually part of
the building and I think this is
something very important because it
feels right
Oh